hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar design
and performance
characteristics of lenny m resp4plex
assay today's educational web seminar is
presented by labruz
and brought to you by global scientific
affairs molecular diagnostics
at abbott we encourage you to
participate today by submitting any
questions you may have during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical
questions here as well
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please follow the process to obtain your
credits by clicking on the continuing
education credits window
i'd like to now welcome our speakers dr
xi huang
senior director of athletic development
molecular diagnostics at abbott
and dr gregory berry director division
of infectious disease diagnostics
department of pathology and laboratory
medicine northwell health
laboratories our speakers will now begin
their presentations
thank you for the introduction uh today
i will present to the audience the
design and performance
of uh the other molecular's first
respiratory multiplex assay
that we developed on the illinois tm
system that detect and differentiate
of differentiate starscope 2 influenza a
b
and rsv
here's the agenda of the presentation
the three parts i will first give a
brief introduction of the respiratory
disease state and also the current trend
overview secondly i will
introduce the design of the illuminati m
red flowplex assay
lastly i will describe some of the key
performance
characteristics of this assay
first disease state and current trend
as we all know we are in a mode in the
middle of the most challenging
kovind 19 pandemic as of
january 20th 2021 the world has seen
almost 100 million total number of
cumulative confirmed kobe 19 cases
ever since who defined kobe 19 as a work
pandemic
in march the has been
ever increasing number of confirmed
cases on a weekly basis
for example since september 2020
to january 2021 the weekly confirmed
cases
has been more than doubled
during the same time there has been a
lot of activities
in introducing uh molecular diagnostic
assay fda as of november 7th 2020
has authorized 189 molecular tests
for emergency use only in the united
states
as we all know typically late fall
winter time
means the advent of multiple seasonal
respiratory viral infections
among the many eoa molecular tests has
been authorized
there are only very few that detect and
differentiate
non-source code 2 respiratory viruses
such as
influenza viruses and rsv
today i will introduce to you our first
album molecular
respiratory multiplex assay but before
that
i will first discuss the biology of the
virus
and also discuss the potential clinical
utility of such a multiplex
assay
first stars code 2. it is a newly
identified
beta coronal virus in cervical virus of
genera
the incubation time is approximately
five days
after exposure symptoms
last for 12 days after onset
patients with mild to moderate symptoms
typically are released from the health
care 10 days after onset
those with severe to critical conditions
are released 10 to 20 days after symptom
onset
patients who are infected can be
infectious before symptoms said
and the starts called two as of january
19 2021
has led to 2 million deaths worldwide
and 0.4 million deaths in the united
states
the next is influenza virus obviously
this is
uh this is one of the predominant
uh contributor for the for the seasonal
respiratory infection
influenza virus is ortho mixovirus
there are two types two main types that
infects human a and b
there are many subtypes for true a and
two main lineages for flu b
worldwide influenza viruses
cause five to three million severe cases
every year
between 290 000 to 650 000 deaths
each year in the united states
these viruses lead to 0.4 to 0.7 million
hospitalization each year
24 000 to 62 000 deaths in the 2019-2020
season
the duration for uncomplicated illness
is one to seven days
this slide shows the seasonal patterns
of the influenza a and b infection
this is based on the influenza positive
test reported cbc
by clinical laboratory in the three most
recent seasons
as you can see the
timing for the infection by influenza a
and b
are significantly overlapping which
means that
at any given time there could be
co-circulating of both viruses
in the same population
next is restaurant trace and facial
virus rsv
it is a pyramid exovirus has two
subtypes a and b
worldwide it is a leading cause of lower
respiratory infection mobility and
mortality
because roughly 34 million acute lower
respiratory infections
annually in children aged less than five
years
it leads to 3.2 million hospital
admissions
50 000 in-hospital deaths in young
children
in the united states rsv
is a leading cause of herculization for
young children less than five years old
the infection of our tea last less than
five days
in healthy adults and roughly seven days
in children similar to the situation
of the circle circulation of flu a and b
that was presented earlier
rsv can also co-circulate with other
virus
this is the data based on who art
surveillance program in the united
kingdom
as you can see again
at a time when there's overlapping
infection there could be
both viruses co-circulating in the same
population
so this phenomenon begs the question
about whether it is important to detect
as well as differentiate multiple
respiratory viruses
to start to address that question let's
first look at the symptoms
these are the symptoms associated with
the three
mentioned viral infections
is clear even though for some symptoms
they may be predominantly associated
with one
versus the other viral infection such as
the recent loss of taste or smell
is predominantly associated with kovin19
however the majority of the symptoms are
very similar
among the three viral infections
symptoms may be similar
the clinical features can be quite
different between different viral
infections
this slide shows the comparison between
flu versus koval19
for flu it takes one to four days to
show symptoms versus
two to fourteen days for chromie 19 to
show symptoms through
is contagious for seven days versus
for covering 19 contagions for longer
which is greater than 10 days
fruit causes less severe illness and
death bone 19 caused more severe illness
and death in addition there are unique
complications associated with kova-19
including blood clots
in veins arteries of long heart legs or
brain
and multisystem inflammatory syndrome in
children
similarly the clinical features can be
different between flu
versus the rfp food starts with a high
fever along with aches and pain
rsv starts with a cold with fever
leading to coughing breathing
fast breathing and wheezing
it takes one to four days to show flu
symptoms
however 46 days to show rsp symptoms
rule is contagious for seven days rg
for three to eight days and it can be
much longer for infants
or people with weakened immune system
the different
clinical features the treatment
for different viral infections can be
very different as well
the treatments for cytoscope 2 influenza
rsv are shown on this slide
so this leads to the discussion of the
clinical utility of the respiratory
multiplex assay
even the overlapping symptoms different
clinical outcomes
different treatments it may be very
important therefore
to provide simultaneous detection
and differentiation for respiratory
viruses in particular starts called two
flu and rsv from the same patient
specimen
in addition such multiplex assay
will provide results that can inform
infectious control measures
and also because this assay targets
multiple analytes
this allow laboratory to process more
tests in a given period
while conserving important testing
materials
that are in short supply
so next i will introduce to you the
design
of the average molecular identity m red
full text asset
i will discuss the pcr design in terms
of the selections of genomic targets
in addition i will discuss the data
reduction and result reporting
this slide shows the basic target
design for that for the assay this assay
provides qualitative detection and
differentiation
of all these viruses through a
for fluid the acid targets the matrix
gene
it targets the non-structural gene for
fluid b
the matrix gene for rsv and the rdrp
and n-gene for starscope 2.
in addition a internal control
based on a non-competitive design is
introduced to the assay
because this internal control contains
non-relevant
trunk gene therefore this signal can be
used to ensure the performance
of reagents and systems
this acid targets highly conserved
sequences for each of the targeted
analytes
this table summarized the large body
of bioinformatical evidence based on the
sequence alignment
of tens of thousands or even hundred
thousands of sequences
from the publicly available in sequences
from the databases
and this analysis confirmed the
confidence
of this target design but
specifically for source code tool
detection
is this assay detects two targets as
mentioned before
one is rna dependent rna polymerase
the other is ng each of the two
target regions is highly conserved the
employment of such a dual
target design allow for redundancy in
the case of very rare
viral mutations the importance
of the selection of conserved target
region
is highlighted by the recent uprising
of the highly virulent stars cultural
variant
from various geographic regions in the
world
our bioinformatical analysis confirmed
that the avid primary probes designed
for the cytoscope 2 assay
are not impacted by this
variants that come from for example
united kingdom
south africa and brazil
i will move on to the data reduction and
software
the signal that is detected for those
target analytes
are processed through this multi-layered
comprehensive systems
that involve signal processing the
evaluation of pcr reactivity
and determination of the validity of the
pcr curve
all of which lead to the report of the
reliable asset result
max ratio technology it is a
proprietary algorithm that is the key
feature
that supports the data reduction
strategy
this maturation technology transformed
the pcr curve
into well-defined peaks
many aspects of this ratio peak reflects
the efficiency
of the pcr reaction and therefore are
used to determine
the validity of the pcr curves
this is one of the again the key
features that ensure
the reliability of the results from
average identity assets
the annuity m system reports clear-cut
straightforward result interpretation
for the specimen that are tested
for each specimen
the selected biomarker that was selected
at the time of sample ordering will be
will be given with a result
as well as interpretation
so this assay is developed on our
molecular
new illinois tm instrument
that were introduced to the u.s market
at the early part of
2020 and this instrument
provides random access to
multiple assays onboard the system
it provides the user the ability to have
continuous access to samples and
reagents
an instrument provides very fast
turnaround time
in fact it's market leading compared to
other major large molecular systems
only tm can process 300 samples per each
eight hours
customer can load up to 20 assets
onboard the system
for urgent sample ordering lntm provides
the stats
prioritization capability
for the last part of the presentation i
will describe to you some of the key
performance
characteristics of this assay
this slide shows the limit of detection
performance
of common strains for stars co2 as well
as
two strings each for influenza a and b
and r t including r g a and b
obviously the analytical sensing
determination in tcid
for each strain viral strain depends on
the specific strain
and the specific lot that are tested in
the study
this slide shows the inclusivity
performance of the assay
in this study a total of 33
viral strains that i analyzed were
tested including six
isolates of star scope ii
15 strains of flu a including i2n1
h3n2 h5n1
h7n2 seven strains of through b
virus including both of the major
lineages
victoria and yamagata and five strains
of rsv
including rsv a and b the assay
is able to detect extremely low target
level for each of tested
inclusivity strains and isolates
in the analytical specificity study a
total of 55 potential cross reactants
were tested
including 31 viruses 21 bacterias
two fungi and a put human nasal wash
no cross reactivity was observed in the
presence of
any of these potential cross reactants
this slide showed shows the precision
performance of the assay
a total of nine panel members consisting
of
two target level of each of the four
amoled stars code two through a through
b
rc as well as a negative panel member
among the up to 30 replicas tested
across five days
one hundred percent agreement was
observed compared to the expected result
and also excellent precision was
demonstrated
by evaluating the sd and percent cv of
the pcr cycle number
the clinical performance of this assay
was evaluated
by testing over a hundred major
pharyngeal
swab specimens collected in viral
transfer media
when compared to the respective
competitor this asset achieved
100 percent positive percent agreement
and 100 or near 100 percent negative
percent agreement
for excellent clinical performance
demonstrated in this study
this slide summarized the assay design
and performance attributes as well as
the workflow attribute
the ice is compatible with multiple
upper respiratory specimen types
it consists of a negative control and
positive control
the ice is highly sensitive for each of
targeted
viral analyte they include
a non-competitive internal control
they report qualitative as a result
with 100 specificity and for clinical
performance 100 ppa or
100 or near 100 mpa
for the workflow in terms of control
the customers only need to run one
control set
consisting of negative and positive
control
once every 24 hours
the sample volume is relatively small
the extraction method is the same as
multiple other aluminium
acids including the single plex
eliminating m star scope 2 assay
less than 2 hours of turnaround time
300 results per each eight hours when
the system is operated continuously in a
24 hour period
more than one thousand results can be
recorded
this system allows the stats function
that is helpful to process urgent
ordering the assay
has the liquid reagent format which is
stable for up to four days
on board the instrument
in summary the unlimited
rest four plex assay is designed
based on scientific foundation
and this assay provides clear and
clinically relevant results to customers
the assay and the system enables
efficient laboratory workflow
in a time of high demand
this asset is an additional tool that
can be used in laboratory testing
clinical management and public health
efforts
so this indicates the end of the
presentation i would like to thank you
for your attention
well thank you dr wong for that great
introduction and i'm really happy to be
here today to discuss this topic with
you
so today we're going to be discussing
the performance of the alinity m
resp4 plex eua assay
and so here are my disclosures uh i am
you know the support for this program is
provided by avid and also i'm
speaking on request of that but
and so the objectives of today's talk
are going to be
to discuss current respiratory and sars
cov2 data from new york
and also then to review our data and
workflow characteristics of the
platforms being used
for respiratory and soros cov2 testing
in our laboratory
and so just to start with a basic
introduction of course of stars cov2
so as we all already know i'm sure but
it always is good to go over
uh soros kobe 2 stands for severe acute
respiratory syndrome coronavirus ii
this was first discovered in december of
2019 in wuhan in the hubei province of
china
the genus is beta coronavirus and
subgenus cervecovirus
the clinical disease is referred to as
covid19 which is
obviously the term that we use most of
the time when we discuss the virus
because we're discussing a lot of
the clinical issues associated with
viral infection
and there have been over 500 000 deaths
in the united states so far
with 50 almost 50 000 deaths alone in
new york state
and so this virus has has had an
enormous toll
over the last year plus on our on
our country on our economy and obviously
on our health
and the first confirmed cases in new
york were at the beginning of march in
2020
and it very quickly became apparent to
everybody that cases were more
widespread
than uh than we had initially hoped for
and here you can see just a little
diagram here on the right hand side of
the screen just looking at the various
pieces of the virus that are targeted by
diagnostic assays
here you see the nuclear capsid you can
see the spike glycoprotein which you
hear a lot about and
the s gene of course encodes for that
you see the envelope small membrane
protein which is the e
you see the membrane protein which is m
so these are all pieces that you hear
as these viruses get discussed and of
course
this is not the first coronavirus to be
around every gear you have four seasonal
coronaviruses that
tend to circulate and these
coronaviruses are the ones that cause
which would be called almost like the
common colds and that's nl63
229 e hku1
and oc43 and when we look at viral
infections during what used to be a
typical respiratory season out of our
100 that were positive if we looked at
that as the whole pie of just positive
results
we would see that these uh combined
would cause about
10 of our respiratory infections so
chronoviruses have been around and this
is obviously
this the new coronavirus which is why
initially it was caught
called the novel coronavirus
and so when we look at the types of
testing for source code v2
you can really think about it as three
big buckets one is molecular which is
the one we talk about a lot
the second one is viral antigen which
can be done
more like in a point of care kind of
environment but also can be done on
large analyzers now
as time has gone on and also serology or
antibody testing which
basically looks at the host immune
response so
almost all of the testing you can think
of will fit into these three buckets
it's really kind of important to
understand how they fit in
and where each test kind of falls so
this was
actually a really nice article in jama
discussing the various types and this
was actually published pretty early on
in the pandemic
and as you can see you have basically
laid out
from left to right you have before
symptom onset and after symptom onset
and of course before symptom onset
especially early on in the pandemic
before people were doing asymptomatic
testing and screening and all these
other
uh types of uh you know testing i mean
really
the symptomatic patients were getting
tested so before some demand said
detection was unlikely
now the reason i point that out is
because not because the pcr would have
been negative because you can see that
blue line there
which is the pcr line and you basically
see
the various sources right in the pcr for
either nasopharyngeal
or you see a bal or a sputum and the
pink line
and then you even see viral isolation
from the respiratory tract which would
indeed be positive
before symptom onset typically but
detection was unlikely because testing
was unlikely
now as time goes on and symptoms you
know start
to occur and then testing occurs but pcr
is likely for the first few weeks of
infection that pcr will still be likely
in fact pcr out in week four
five and six while it says here that pcr
is likely negative
you know we've come to find out that
there are patients that are
that have uh positive pcr results
sometimes out over two months
and so while it's unlikely that pcr
would be positive it's definitely not
um it's not uncommon but antibody
detection is thought to be after the
first few weeks of infection really the
uh
what will end up being the test that
won't be diagnostic
but will be the test to indicate that
you were infected and you see the dotted
lines
both the purple being the igm and the
green being the igg you can see them
coming up
you know at the end of week one and then
they
basically spike and then what happens is
the igg stays persistent and the igm
will wane over time but they both come
up at virtually the same time
the molecular tests and of course the
rapid antigen tests when they're used
are thought to be diagnostic whereas i
said the uh the antibody tests are
thought more to be
for epidemiologic purposes and to
understand immunity
and so when we look at diagnostic
testing in new york city
i just wanted to show this to kind of
give you an idea of the lay of the land
as far as molecular
diagnostic testing versus using rapid
antigen tests
and you can see that consistently
molecular tests have been used
i mean this is a data pull just from
january to early march
and you can see that drop off at the end
in gray that's just because basically
those days were incomplete data because
the data hadn't been collated yet
but if you look you see this consistent
around 60 000 tests a day that spike
through the week and then drop on the
weekend but you see this consistent 60
000 line
and you see that while rapid antigens um
you know while there are rapid energies
being done they kind of have stayed at
us at a steady state
that is lower than the pcr rate so you
know there's still a lot of our
molecular rate
so there's still a lot of molecular
testing being done
i think one interesting topic that
people have been thinking about that
i've definitely been thinking about
as you go forward are we going to start
to see a seasonality for sarsko v2
and so the reason is is because you know
we see a seasonality for these four
coronaviruses that are already
circulating
and this was actually from the swiss med
weekly back in early 2020
uh looking at seasonality and trying to
make the comparison so this was
basically looking at
coronaviruses not service kobe 2 in
stockholm sweden
between 2010 and 2019 and it's really
interesting to watch that aggregate data
and watch as it works across months you
can see these peaks that
that tend to happen at around this
immunity falling around this 40-week
interval so it's really kind of
interesting
when we specifically look at some of the
coronaviruses
and this this cadence of what it is to
be immune and then lose immunity
and you tend to see the seasonality that
falls in place
which is i'm which is always on people's
mind about what's going to happen with
with now with stars cov2
as far as immunity goes you can
basically see in panel and you just see
that spike
you see that spike that yearly spike and
then panel b
you see basically that weaning over the
summer time and then that
re-emergence as the fall comes in
i think that
conversation about if this is going to
happen and we're going to get a
seasonality like we do with the other
coronaviruses
then what other viruses are we going to
need to test concurrently
which will be circulating at the same
time
and so when we look at testing guidance
for clinicians
during what would be what was
traditionally the flu season
now incorporating sars cov2 into this
this scenario
so you get a circulation of flu rsv and
source code v2 all at the same time so
what are the recommendations right
so this is for the outpatient clinic or
emergency room
uh patients that you that have acute
respiratory illness and come in
whether or not they have a fever and so
basically you have two questions does
the patient need to be admitted
okay let's say yes the patient does need
to be admitted well you're going to want
to do
source cov2 and at least influenza
testing right so that patient's going to
need both
because obviously they could have flu or
they could have stars cov2
especially moving forward into the next
season while we've seen
very very low rates of flu this year i
think that this was
an exceptionally an exceptionally
interesting year as far as flu spread
because of
masking and because of social distancing
so as this falls into a seasonality
it's quite clear to me and to others
that that you know other respiratory
viruses are obviously going to be in the
mix and will also need to be tested for
particularly flu and rsv and so
the patient needs to be hospitalized
it's pretty obviously need flu testing
if they don't need to be hospitalized uh
soros cov2 testing could potentially be
right now the uh the path that they
could go down
also though influenza testing is is not
a bad idea and you can see here in the
second point where it talks about
influential testing and treatment
but i mean this this obviously has an
impact on how we're going to
how we're going to test moving into the
future
and so when we talk about respiratory
testing including source cov2
and molecular specifically here at
northwell
i'll just give you a background first on
our health system and then discuss what
we do as forest testing
so northward health is actually a large
health system in long island
and also in new york city and up into
the westchester region
uh we're predominantly in long island we
have other sites as you can see
in manhattan and also in westchester and
we have uh
you know several affiliated hospitals
we're up over 20 hospitals now
and a lot of this hospital work is
either done on-site
uh for for respiratory source code v2 or
it comes into the
the core labs and it's really a
mix-and-medly of both depending on
on how depending on what the needs of
specific hospitals are
and the outpatient work mostly almost
all of that comes into the
into the overall core labs if molecular
testing is needed
and so when we talk about the models of
testing typically what we're doing here
is centralized testing we're either
doing it at a core central lab
or we're doing it in this top panel
right at a satellite lab which would be
a satellite lab at the hospitals
we refer to these as rapid response labs
those are basically our
our hospital-based labs were are rapid
and stat testing needs to be done and
respiratory testing falls into that
bucket
uh especially because of patient
cohorting and the need to have that
answer quickly
right we also have professional point of
care that gets done at doctor's offices
specifically at clinics by medical staff
and it gets tested on site so that is
also
a proportion of our work but i mean most
of what i'm talking about today is the
either the core lab or the satellite
labs and specifically the core labs in
this case
and so when i talk about profit 19
diagnostic testing at northwell i really
was thinking about it
initially as a sprint that turned into a
marathon and it's a marathon that
continues
uh to this day really so pre-covered 19
even last flu season we were really
running three different tests we were
running gen mark respiratory panels in
the health system
uh for for the larger um you know viral
panels for luminex we were running flu a
b and rsv and for cepheid
at the core lab and then at cepheid at
the hospitals for flu a b and rsv
so it was you know we actually had i
think a little bit more diversity than
most
for as far as our respiratory testing
but i mean it really was not that much
when we go and we look now at the
situation from march 2020
onward um from there we needed to
to very rapidly get coveted 19
diagnostic testing up and running um we
started with the modified cdc assay on
actually on a sunday night which was
march 8th
uh of 2020 march 8th of last year we
very recently watched the anniversary of
that testing
go by and just reflected on how
how insane of a year it really had been
as far as
standing up testing and continuing to
test uh we shortly thereafter we went
live with the gen mark which allowed us
to go from about 100 a day up to
hundreds of tests a day
then we went live with the pianterfusion
which which put us on more of the
industrial scale of thousands of tests a
day
we brought in the dioceran as more of a
stat test where we could do
quick uh testing that didn't require the
larger platforms
and then it was very obvious to us we
also had to roll out testing to the
hospitals right so at the hospitals
we ran into everything from a cepheid to
an id now
to a denmark to an abbott m2000 and even
a a small platform called biome at the
hospitals for a little while
just to keep testing up and running and
then we even uh brought in panther
fusions into the core lab i mean panther
aptoma actually on on tma into the core
lab
which brought us up to the 5 000 a day
range
and as we talked about the core lab
we then brought on besides putting
panthers at six of our hospitals we also
brought in the pan
the uh the abilities at the actual core
laboratories which we brought in one
ability and then we brought in two more
abilities
and we also have a roche 800 just trying
to build capacity through that
june july august september time frame
and
i wrote here we were still building
capacity october through december what i
meant to say is october through present
because
even right now we're still having
conversations about building capacity
although we're starting to kind of see
where
um we we have built enough capacity to
handle the health system and we've do
we've diversified enough
so any increase we may see as long as
it's uh
not uh completely disproportionate
and so when we talk about the large
respiratory platforms that we have
uh for source cov2 testing we really
have the abbot uh
we have the ability we have the panther
system and the panther fusion actually
and so basically if you look at that
system
the panther fusion is just the piece
that's on the left if you took that off
then you would have a panther
and the cobas 8800 and so these are
really three large uh large platforms
for
for high volume testing both the
linearity and the fusion could do about
a thousand samples a day
the cobas 800 could do about 3 200
samples in a day
and you could see the various times to
result on these platforms but these are
all large
large platforms for large high volume
testing
and so what we really wanted to do was
when we brought the elites in we wanted
to see
how they would compete with our other
assays that do flu a b and rsv testing
because we were doing
stars code v2 in all three of these
platforms now we wanted to bring in the
next
um the next generation of testing with
abbott
and really check out how the alinity m
was going to perform
with their fourplex and so their four
plex was actually their fourplex was
actually a flu a b
rsv covet
and so here's just a disclosure about
eua about emergency use authorization
that just basically said that this
product has not been fda cleared or
approved but it's been authorized via
the eu a pathway
and it's for detection of source code v2
flu a fluid b and rsv
and you know basically the uh the
the legal implications of what eua means
right down here on the bottom
and so what we did in this case was we
actually evaluated the linearity m
fourplex and we compared that to the
cepheid fourplex which we previously had
and had been using
and the and also the cobas uh
sars kobe 2 flu a and b and of course
you know the
the expert express is made by cepheid
and that's the geniux
expert express and the the cobas
uh is made by rosh and his the system is
the cobas lia
and so what we did is select uh
both stars cov2 positive specimens and
flu a b rsv positive specimens
uh using various clinical platforms that
we already were doing patient testing on
so we used aptima basically to collect
all of our source code v2 positive
specimens
and then we used either the aries or the
gen mark e plex
the luminex areas of the denmark e-plex
to collect flu abrsv
specimens and then we tested them on the
alina dm
on the on the expert express and on the
kovas
sarskovy ii to do a head-to-head head
comparison
and what we found when we looked at the
alinity uh
agreement when we compared it to the
cepheid in both the liaids so i'll go
with the short names of cepheid and the
liat
we basically found that they all had a
very high degree
of positive percent agreement uh 100
negative percent agreement across the
board for all analytes
and basically the only difference that
you see at 95 positive agreement
was the cepheid for rsv versus the
alinity
and you basically look at the cepheid
source kobe 2 versus the alinity
and so a very high degree of
of comparability between the platform
one thing i want to point out is you see
that cepheid rsv's is the only rsv
comparator to linity that's because the
liaise does not have rsv it only has flu
flu a b and source cov2 so that's an
important difference just to point out
if you were wondering
in addition what we did was an lod study
so
it was important for us to actually look
at the limit of detection to try to
understand the sensitivity of these
platforms and uh
and what we used was actually a
theracure panel for both stars cov2 and
rsv and then we use zeptometrics for flu
a b as reference material and what we
found was
that if we look at where the cutoffs
were for the lods and the number of
replicates you see we did between five
and ten replicates at each concentration
uh you saw that the respiratory four
plex for the uh
for the alinity actually continued down
to 12.5 copies per ml
so just above that is basically where
you start to see
less than 100 percent agreement when we
looked at the
lea we basically saw that at 100 copies
he started to lose
his flu a and then source covey v2 is
the most sensitive
at 25 copies we we lost we were less
than 100
when you look at the cepheid um the
cepheid product
you basically see that rsv is good to
about 200 copies per ml
source code v2 is good to about 50
copies per ml
and then you see flu a one of the fluid
targets and the fluid b
target good to 12 about 12.5 right above
12.5
so overall a very good performance from
from all three systems i mean
if you look at these copy numbers this
is quite good and
the alinity i think not surprising
knowing that it's a large it's a large
platform with a larger
uh you know extraction volume etc and
also a longer cycling time
actually is the most sensitive of these
three
and furthermore um this was actually a
study done with externally sourced
remnant specimens uh and this was
actually done at abbott
looking at respiratory fourplex eua
assay agreement
uh between methods that were already
510k
cleared so these are fda approved assets
for flu and rsv
so they could understand basically how
their product was
competing was competing with what was
already on the market so you know the
whole logic panther fusion flu abrsv
was already on the market the previous
year and is fda approved
and the gen mark e flex respiratory
pathogen panel was the
panel that was the respiratory panel
previously so you see that
there were they had 52 fluids swine flus
or seasonal h3s
47 flu bees and 51 rsvs both
rsv a and b positive specimens and you
could see that there was a very high
level of agreement between
all three of the targets between 98 and
100
so the assay performed very well when
comparing to
already fda approved tests
and so in conclusion really the
comparative respiratory assays all
perform similarly
uh with a ppa greater than or equal to
95 an npa of 100
which is great the comparator assays
were a little bit less sensitive than
the alinity when you looked at the the
overall lod studies
there was a high degree of agreement uh
with observed
uh comparison between two fda approved
assays
when flew an rsv which were the
obviously the previous products were
checked
and comparator platforms in this study
had a lower testing volume capability
compared to the alinity system
you know we're talking about systems
that are are more
sample to answer systems that are that
could be done in smaller labs
versus a larger volume that could be
done like 120 specimens loaded at once
in the alinity
but their patient care utility may be
very different you know a liat or a
cephe is going to
potentially go in a different type of
laboratory
a smaller volume laboratory than than a
linear dm not in all cases but in some
cases so it's just
it all comes down to kind of where what
your patient population is what your
numbers are for testing and then
also what your turnaround times are for
testing and this all needs to be
considered and it is all very important
but i think most important from this
study was basic performance
characteristics which
which were quite good
and really when we look at a path
forward for respiratory testing uh
you know i think respiratory testing is
soros cov2 testing now
built in right and so we're going to
need to continue to build
diversification for
for respiratory testing in general
including stars kobe 2.
i think there's going to be continuing
evaluation of testing performance to
understand
um which tests to use
and which tests are performing well and
also as we start to see more variants
and situations like this it's obviously
going to be
very important to watch uh testing
performance moving forward by both in
clinical labs where
it's likely to get identified up front
and then also to feed this information
back to manufacturers and
and the fda so everybody's aware of what
the real-time data is
i think performance characteristics
along with supply chain realities will
both need to be considered when choosing
platforms
and vaccination obviously is going to
hopefully impact testing demands in the
upcoming several months
and we're very hopeful about that
especially looking at the performance of
the vaccines thus far
and so with that i would like to just
thank the northwell health department of
pathology and lab medicine and my
colleagues there dr weizen
betsy smith and rihanna mangy and all
the awesome members of of my molecular
team who do the clinical testing
and i'd also like to thank abbott and dr
daniela lucic for her
for her generous support of this study
and also for helping us out
with all of these new products and i
really appreciate that so with that i'll
take any questions
and i just thank you for your time
and we've put together some frequently
asked questions
we would like to discuss our first
question dr wong what is the difference
in sars kovi ii limit of detection
between the alinity
m stars co v2 singleplex
assay and the resp four 4-plex assay
and why are there different units of
measurement
that's a good question so
the many of the design principles are
really very much the same between the
eliminator and single plex
assays and the four part methods
so that's reflected to the performance
attribute
in particular for limited detection both
acids report
linear detection in tcid as well as
either copy or genomic genome equivalent
the copy and genome equivalent are
really equivalent kind of unit or
measure
and as reflected in the product labeling
the claim for the linear detection are
really quite similar between the two
assets essentially the same
thank you very much sir and with the
alinity m
resp fourplex assay do i need to report
all four markers when i run the test
that's another good question the lntm
software
allows the multi-text assay
enabled to enable the customer at the
time of ordering the result
the sample processing to select
different combinations either single or
different combinations of
bar markers at a time of ordering for
this particular multiplex assay this is
the the full flex assay
for eoa when customer ordered this ua
assay
the sars code 2 needs always to be
selected
but besides stars code 2 the other three
viruses can be selected in
any combination
thank you and will the fourplex assay be
available
on the m2000
so uh our molecular developed this four
plaque assay with a mind
to support a customer uh
in the midst of the pandemic where
there's a high demand of
acid reagents and the laboratory
throughput
the combination of the multiplex
aspect as well as the operational
efficiency offered by the illinois m
system
is a ideal combination
to enable the customer to achieve their
goal
obviously the instrument features one
2000
is different and uh at this point
before pastor assay this uh is not
available on m2000 but uh
when uh a time comes in the future
when that need become obvious that
certainly will be
considered as well
thank you very much and moving on dr
wong can i run both single stars kobe 2
assay and the resp 4-plex assay at the
same time on the idling em
so so this uh question really is related
to one of the key features
that the ltm system offers which is the
what we call random access
what that means is that when we have
multiple assets
loaded on the system waiting to be used
the uh for any incoming sample
right uh any of the loaded assets can be
selected
uh were applicable as needed for the
incoming specimen
so uh it could be asset one with a
sample one
and acid two with example two so the
answer is yes
so uh a single price uh
starts cultural assay versus a full text
assay
is they're not special in this manner at
all
as all the other assets for our limited
system
this actually can be run together
thank you so much dr wong and our next
question is what is the time
to first result and throughput for the
four plex
assay does it take longer than the
olynym assays
so maybe to address this question
um i can kind of continue
on my answer to the last question
because that's related
the the workflow under the hood
of this system uh is such that that
enables the random access
actually rely on uh the process
basically lead to the same uh
uh same turnaround time for all the
athletes
right so as i mentioned in my slide the
turn around time for
full practice assay is less than two
hours 115 minutes
115 minutes and that really is the same
among all the assets on olymputem
systems
thank you so much and our final question
what
monitoring steps are in place to ensure
the four-plex assay as well as
single-plex assays will continue to
detect future variants of the stars kobe
2.
uh that's a very good and relevant
question
and um obviously we have seen
the uh increasing uh variance of source
codes two
that's been reported and we are at
rabbit
keeping a close look at the situation
we are doing a regular sequence analysis
based on the database that i mentioned
in the slide
in addition albert has this global
surveillance program
uh that is monitoring constantly
monitoring the performance of the new
strings
by doing not only the bioinformatics
work but also actively
procuring specimens that potentially
contains
the polymorphisms and to be able to
analyze directly
the impact on assay performance
dr wong thank you so much for your
presentation today would you like to
provide any closing comments
before we go sure thanks for the
opportunity to present
to the customers and introduce to them
this very exciting
multiplexed respiratory assets from
other molecular
we believe this asset performance
combined with the
performance of the system can offer
customers something that's
tangibly better than what they're facing
what they're using today
and i have to say also that as a
after developer as part of the bigger
upper molecular r d
team we have been working
very hard and there are many dedicated
hard-working colleagues
and we're very honored to
be part of the effort to introduce such
an important product
uh that we hope can be effective too
in the fight against the kobe 19
challenge
thank you dr huang and dr barry for your
informative presentations
we would also like to thank labruz and
our sponsor
global scientific affairs molecular
diagnostics at abbott
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by our speakers
via the contact information you provided
at the time
of registration this webcast can be
viewed on demand
lab roots will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye